aujourd'hui nous allons à la rencontre
de Maximin Payet qui a bénéficié de
l'aide de balance une aide du
département qui souhaite accompagner des
producteurs indépendants de fruits et
légumes allons voir ça
[Musique]
nous voici aujourd'hui sur
l'exploitation de maxima agriculteurs
spécialisé dans la lentille à Cilaos qui
a bénéficié de l'aide du département que
l'on nomme headbalance une aide qui
permet d'acquérir une balance
électronique réglementaire neuve
permettant l'enregistrement des
opérations de pesées ainsi que
l'identification et les volumes des
produits vendus bonjour Monsieur et
Madame Payet bonjour tout d'abord merci
de nous accueillir sur votre
exploitation
racontez-nous pourquoi avoir fait la
demande d'une nouvelle balance
de fruits et légumes avec le département
qui avait des aides pour les balances
aussi donc on a en profiter et puis
voilà et on a monté notre dossier et
comment est-ce que vous avez entendu
parler de cette aide les réseaux sociaux
on a vu qu'il y avait
des aides pour la balance et j'ai choisi
entre les deux la balance qui qui allait
mieux qui
m'intéressait plus on a eu remplacement
avec le département de 75% donc alors
expliquez-nous à quoi vous sert
précisément cette nouvelle balance
panneaux de compter de combien de
lentilles qu'on fait dans la journée
pour les autres produits aussi et de
calculer
tout ce qu'on a fait toute la journée on
a besoin de ça parce que le problème
c'est que chaque fois il faut que quand
on vend un kilo de lentilles ou un
kilote il fallait prendre le silo et
noter et là c'était pas c'est pas la
peine donc on gagne du temps et après le
soir on a tout ce qu'on a fait quoi tout
ce qu'on a vendu et tout le drapeau
combiné c'est plus pas c'est plus facile
à nous de calculer combien combien on a
vendu en anti combien on a vendu en live
et la recette aussi combien on a gagné
c'est le top c'est bien merci Monsieur
Madame Payet
le département a souhaité accompagner
l'amélioration de la traçabilité des
opérations de commercialisation des 12
fruits et légumes soutenus dans le cadre
du programme d'accompagnement des
producteurs indépendants bonjour
Florence bonjour Alexandre alors
pourquoi le département a-t-il mis en
place ce dispositif alors ce dispositif
a été mis en place par le département
pour permettre à l'agriculteur de se
professionnaliser on lui a porté une
aide financière pour faire l'acquisition
de la balance électronique donc ça lui
permet de d'être plus précis au niveau
de ses ventes le prix au kilo
globalement d'être plus au fait au
niveau de sa comptabilité expliquez-nous
que fallait-il faire pour bénéficier de
cette aide est venue en complémentarité
avec l'aide au producteurs indépendant
des fruits et légumes donc avec cette
aide là on a un ex il y avait ce un
formulaire de à remplir et ensuite il
fallait juste qu'ils fournisse soit un
devis soit une facture et donc là d'été
à hauteur de 75% pour un montant maximum
de 1500 euros et à ce combien
d'agriculteurs ont pu bénéficier de
cette aide alors aujourd'hui il y a à
peu près une trentaine d'agriculteurs
qui ont pu bénéficier de sa tête grâce
au département merci Florence merci
Alexandre
grâce à cet accompagnement du
département les agriculteurs réunionnais
bénéficient d'un outil précis qui leur
permet d'analyser le fonctionnement de
leur école et d'apporter des changements
pour maintenir la croissance et la
productivité tout en gérant leur stock
plus facilement
[Musique]
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations sur l'aide balance
n'hésitez pas vous avez toutes les
coordonnées qui s'affichent sur votre
écran le département des générations
c'est fini si vous souhaitez revoir cet
épisode ainsi que les précédents
rendez-vous sur nos sites et nos réseaux
sociaux
la semaine prochaine je vous emmène
découvrir le dispositif R+ Cie un
nouveau dispositif mis en place par le
département qui réunit le R+ et le
contrat initiative emploi Cie en
associant leurs avantages respectifs de
manière à ce que tous les employeurs les
employés la collectivité soit gagnant
[Musique]